Michael Turner is a theoretical
cosmologist a Meritus professor at the
University of Chicago and former
director of The kav Institute for
cosmological physics he's a Pioneer in
exploring what he called the dark side
of the universe he actually coined the
term dark energy and his revolutionary
ideas led to the cold Dark Matter theory
of structure formation Mike's
contributions to Modern physics are
truly invaluable and I'm beyond thrilled
to have him as a guest on my show join
us in a deep dive into the dark side of
our Twisted Universe welcome everybody
to a very important meaningful and
delightful episode of the into the
impossible podcast with an impossibly
brilliant guest who I've been uh really
you know in love with his mind since I
was a we lad a graduate student uh he's
a legend in the field and it's uh
Professor Michael Turner University of
Chicago a theoretical cosmologist who
among many things is rumored to have
coined the term Dark Energy Michael is
that correct did you coin the term Dark
Energy guilt guilty as
charged who could the I guess Wiki
coined the term dark matter in German
correct that's right I can't pronounce
the German dunco mat or something like
that yeah I think you're you're closer
than I'll ever get to it uh Michael
where are you joining us from today um
I'm joining uh from my office in Venice
California I appreciate your time and
whatever you'll spare in person or
online but Michael we have a lot to talk
about we'll run out of time before I run
out of questions uh begar forbearance as
we go into the very first question that
I ask all my guests who honor me with uh
their presence on my humble podcast and
that is to judge a book by its cover and
in your case your book with Rocky colb
your uh colleague at the University of
Chicago uh has uh really influenced
generations of of cosmologists of of
theoretical particle physicist
astrophysicist uh experimentalist like
myself and I want to do the following if
you will to judge the book by its cover
I would like you to describe the cover
art the cover title and the subtitle how
did you and Rocky C come up with that
the original hardback version had a very
boring cover it was just White and the
words early universe and if my memory
serves me correct there was no
subtitle and and um the paperback
version which you may be referring to uh
has a wonderful story with it the cover
is a beautiful image of a galaxy
actually for its time I mean today we
get much better images from uh jwst and
and the Hubble so the title that was
exceedingly easy um Rocky and I uh were
pioneers of studying the first
microsc and uh I like to to tell the
joke by the time we got to cosmology you
know everybody specializes all that was
left was the first
microsc and that is the early universe
but we got there at a very good time
because the early Universe had just
opened up shortly before we got there
you couldn't talk about the early
Universe because it was just a mess uh
it was nuclei and protons and neutrons
sitting on top of one another and we
were there when the doors opened when
people realized that it was cork soup
and early Universe it you know a good
title's got to be simple it's got to
have
cosmology and uh early was where it was
at do you want to hear the paperback
version yeah because we're going to
springboard from the paperback to a
discussion of these peculiar properties
of galaxies which in my mind Michael I'm
not going to teach I'm not going to let
the student teach the master but a
galaxy is not exactly at least when I
was a kid an early Universe phenomenon
of the first microsc so yes how did that
come to be the whirpool Galaxy so that's
perfect our our our book did really
really well um and it was going into
paper back and I was in Aspen Colorado
and they sent the artwork to me for the
new
cover and it was this beautiful picture
of a
galaxy and uh I called up
Rocky um and he said well you got the
cover artwork what do you think and I
said it's beautiful but it has nothing
to do with our book and and he said
we'll take it so our book is about the
first microsc but that's where the
blueprint for the universe got laid out
and that's where galaxies can trace
their Origins to so it's not quite fair
to say that uh it was a bait and switch
that it's not really about the pretty
galaxies you see in the sky but the
cover was chosen because oh my god well
the I wish I had could easily get copies
here it's so funny Rocky and I pioneered
a lot of ground there I think we were
book number 69 and David we we asked
David to make some changes because he
had a standard preface that talked about
um you know these are not to be designed
to be polished and uh they're typically
from mograph notes yeah and we said to
David David what is a mograph machine
and uh so we changed some of his uh
forward but they had a standard you know
that's important when you have a brand
Frontiers in physics was a brand and it
was very simple it was white and blue
but then when some other publishing
company took it over and did the
paperback they made it really fancy it's
still in the top 200 of books in
astrophysics even you know it's uh
coming up on its 30th 30th Anniversary
incredible of the of the second edition
I think yeah and I just I just got a
royalty check yesterday wow well that's
that's uh that's uh what all us authors
uh make our make our living yeah and I'm
going to go to Starbucks and have a
coffee on it all right well let's get
into some of the topics in there but
particularly I wanted to be a little
personnic and and kind of poke fun yeah
the Galaxy is sitting there and we've
heard a lot lately about conflicts not
only with the structure formation within
Lambda CDM Lambda cold Dark Matter uh
model the prevailing Paradigm I would
say not only that but whether or not the
big bang even happened I don't know if
you paid attention to this there's some
Fringe I won't call them crack Poots I
won't call them cranks I'll I'll let
somebody else do that but there are
people out there that are claiming and
getting tremendous amount of attention
even from all the way up to Elon Musk
who was a physics major at upen for some
time as I understand it but he tweeted
out and Joe Rogan who's become a friend
of mine tweeted out things about this
but anyway Michael what do you make of
this controversy is it uh Tempest in a
Celestial teapot as Dawkins might say uh
yes um so um but let let me that you
know the the rich science is more
complicated than was there a big bang or
not uh it's never yes or no and I like
to organize my thinking in science about
things we know for sure that are never
going away so one thing we know for sure
that's never going away is the universe
is expanding I would add to that we also
know that the UN the expansion is
speeding up we can get to Dark Energy
later so the universe is expanding we
have so much evidence for that that's no
never going away well if it's if it's
getting bigger than in the past it was
smaller and so if you extrapolate its
size all the way back the extrapolations
would say uh you know the number better
than I do 13.8 billion years ago it had
zero
size uh and that's called the Big Bang
um and the Big Bang Theory is you know
one of those funny things in science
it's not a theory about the Big Bang
it's a theory about the events after the
big bang so the stuff that we know for
sure the the number one thing we know
for sure is that the Universe was much
much smaller in the past and I would say
that the one number one thing we know
for sure how you know when you say how
small do you really mean zero very very
very very strong evidence takes it back
to a size that is 10 trillion times
smaller than it is today that's a lot
smaller does it take it back to zero no
and one of the big questions in um
cosmology that's going to take a while
to answer is was there a big bang was
there ever a time when the universe had
zero size and that's a really rich
question another thing we know for sure
that you know for sure youve spent your
career studying it is it was a hot big
bang so it it wasn't just any old big
bang in the past it was really hot and I
I don't know if you're allowed to use
words like this on your show but I use
it in it in the technical sense it was
hotter than hell and uh so that comes to
us from the cosmic microwave background
the the there's a microwave echo of the
big bang and that we can even get a
picture of the universe it's 13.8
billion years old today we can get a
picture of the universe when it was only
380,000 years old the infant Universe
not 380,000 years ago but when it was
380,000 years old before galaxies and
stars and all that so the idea that I
mean if you want to you know have an
Oxford debate about you know whether or
not there was a big bang then if I were
arguing no there wasn't I would say well
the Big Bang is you know when the
universe was Zero size and we can't
really say that but the idea that the
Universe was much much smaller much much
hotter and uh grew to a size today
that's that's really the Big Bang Theory
which is the events after the big bang
and I know there are people some of them
are Engineers some of them have degrees
I think there's someone who even wrote a
book called The Big Bang never happened
Eric larner that's right he's a provoc I
bought his book I shouldn't have done it
but I did it because I was giving a
lecture a public lecture in Aspen when
the book came out and his in fact you
will enjoy this I hope his number one
piece of evidence it was a very long
book with a lot of words but he had one
piece of evidence was we hadn't found
the small variations in the intensity of
the microwave background that need to be
there to explain galaxies and what was
funny about this book is it literally
written 6 months before those variations
were discovered and made your career
possible because your whole career has
been spent doing this extraordinarily
hard work of studying these tiny tiny
variations that give us a picture of the
infant universe and you know this and
and most scientists this is science is a
continuing process where I would say
we're we're very firm on understanding
the universe back to a microsecond and
earlier than that I would that that goes
into my second bin of really well
formulated ideas that are knocking at
the door door to become fact and
inflation is one of those ideas knocking
at the door to become fact another idea
that's knocking at the door to become
fact is that the dark matter that we
just touched upon very briefly earlier
uh is made of uh Elementary particles
left over from The Big Bang that is not
fact you know I would never you know say
that that's fact we have a lot of
evidence for it but it's really banging
at the door but we don't have the case
for it yet likewise for inflation
there's a lot of um and so it's really
easy to you know throw mud and get a
headline the Big Bang never happened you
know if I said oh the Big Bang happened
we found another piece of evidence for
it and I go to the editor of your you
know the San Diego Union paper can I get
that on the front page N I don't think
so I have someone who will say the Big
Bang never happened can I get that on
the front page oh yeah yeah that's right
that's the uh the big Bang's bleeding so
it's leading um exactly yeah I I make a
lot of that I made a video refuting Mr
learner of the plasma physics Institute
uh of Western Phil uh Pennsylvania and
and that's fine there there's another
gentleman uh Reena Gupta at the
University of Ottawa who's an actual
professor and has worked in this field
and he reduced the age of the universe
you know from infinity and static to um
to a mere 27 billion
and you know I'm happy to talk to these
people I generally think along the lines
of Lord Martin Ree that you know debate
is pointless it's it's not like people
change their mind uh you know they love
to hear debates they love to watch
debates but it's like a baseball game
you go and see your your bears and and
you don't want them to uh to to lose
it's not like you you really want to you
know see a great M no you want them to
blow the other team out at least I do
with the Padres we know the Bears are
going to lose unfortunately yeah I know
well the same with the Padres but at
least you've had a team that you know at
least the Cubs have won World Series the
Padre's never have but let's turn to uh
to inflation because uh as I said before
we press record your papers were really
influential on on experimentalist and I
don't know if you realize that but but a
lot of us who you know began our careers
you know in in the 90s with with Colin
Turner later turned our attention to the
search for some circumstantial but NE um
nevertheless very probative information
about inflation were to occur and one of
the most influential papers on a
generation my generation was you know
your papers on the scorecard for
inflation and I don't know if you can
you know take us back to to what it
meant when you prepare these um uh these
these papers do you do you think about
the audience as being you know
particular people like young Brian Kings
experimentalist phenomenologist how do
you how did you develop the brand of uh
and the taste that you have to develop
things that would be of great utility to
theorist Observers and experimentalist
what goes be what went into that thought
process of that particular series of
papers in science there are people who
just want to be clever and write clever
papers some of the theorists are that
way and that that's really important to
have clever ideas and tools out there
and um and then then there are people
who um would like to have clever ideas
that are
testable and let's see if they're right
or wrong and if they're wrong oh
whatever but if they're right that's
that's very very cool and uh early
Universe
cosmology um underwent a
transition uh in the early days we were
just having a lot of fun I mean we we
would invent a new kind of universe
every week and and uh discovery of those
small variations in the uh intensity of
the microwave background uh in 1992
April 23rd that was a really big deal
because that meant you could really
start testing these ideas I've gone on
record many places saying this I've said
it in a lot of papers Alan Goose theory
of inflation is the second most
important idea in cosmology ever after
the big bang after George gamma's Big
Bang whether or not it's right and it
has directed The Field um since his 1980
paper it might have been 198 81 when it
was published and so starting in the
early 90s there was the idea you might
be able to test this Theory and it's a
theory about events that happened a
jiffy after the big bang you you know
what a jiffy is right yeah it's a sco
it's a little more than a sco yeah
that's right it's it's a micros sco and
oh no maybe it's a it's t scoes I always
get that screwed up so very early you
know maybe 10 Theus 35 seconds and so
you want to guide people you also um and
I want to test this on you sometimes
people think science is a cabal right
Brian and Michael work together and so
big big cosmology yeah conspiratorial
cosmology Brian wants to confirm
Michael's ideas and then you know blah
blah blah and and typically the best
compliment an experimentalist can pay to
a theorist is to try to disprove the
theorist's idea and inflation was like
that its boldest prediction
and this was slightly before your time
but one of your mentors was involved in
this its absolute boldest prediction was
that the universe is flat that it has
the critical density and the astronomers
used to roll their eyes because they
said oh my God the we already know that
the density is not the critical density
it's only 10% and so you know we love
that inflation and the false vacuum
energy and all that stuff but changed
the flat universe and maybe later I'll
tell you a story about where it almost
got changed but it didn't and we stuck
with the flat universe and uh then Dark
Energy came along and the person who
showed that that was the first major
test of inflation because all the
evidence at the time uh which was not
perfect it was just based upon counting
up matter and you could only count up
matter um close to galaxies said no you
missed by a factor of 10 that's that's a
pretty big error one of your I assume he
was one of your your mentors Andrew Lang
at Caltech he was your postdoctoral
Mentor I think that's right yeah he and
I made bicep and I don't know if you
were involved in his boomerang
experiment it was aall I wasn't no he
hired me after I got fired by Sarah
Church at Stanford and then but she
kindly arranged for a meeting with
Andrew Lang who had been her postto
advisor and then the rest as they say
his history and we went on with Jamie
Bach to build bicep and then bicep I
hope we get to that cuz I am I am just
in love with bicep as a father I I take
I take great uh satisfaction but anyway
Andrew's balloon
experiment uh was fantastic and that's
how I met Andrew we we were together on
the NASA press conference and we flew
back from Washington DC to Chicago I had
booked him for a colloquium and that
that was the first big piece of evidence
and then the what you what you have
spent most of your career studying these
small variations in the intensity of the
microwave background across the sky
about a part in 10 to the five really
really small very very hard to measure
that's a big area where you where you
could where you could test it uh how do
they vary from angle to angle and
getting more technical what are their
statistics and so on and so forth and so
you got to spell that out first of all
if you ever want your if you ever want
people to say oh you made a prediction
and it was confirmed you got to make the
prediction before it was confirmed after
it's confirmed you say oh yeah no no no
that's what I predicted retrodiction
yeah yeah my neighbors do that you know
every everybody does that Eric learner
does that but you've got to get the
predictions and you also have to say
here's what's really important one of
the ones I take the most pride in in
that paper these variations we have this
term called scale invariant so they they
don't change from scale to
scale but a very important thing is
they're not scale invariant they're
almost scale inv variant and um I
believe um my collaborators and I were
the first ones to put that word in front
of there saying an important test is
that they're not quite scale inv variant
so they're close but they're 10% off and
if you find them to be exactly scale
invariant that that would not be a
feather in inflation's hat you want them
to be slightly off and they indeed are
10% off and and the experimentalists
really paid attention to that that was a
big goal can we show that there's a
statistically significant deviation from
scale invariance and then the one that
the big one and I think most of my
papers um I'm glad I was detecting the
gravity wave signature which at the time
when I when when I started writing it'
be interesting to go back and look at
the paper that was going to be that was
so difficult to do there was no that one
looked undoable but you if you're a
theorist you can't say oh by the way
here's a really cool prediction but
you're never going to do it you've got
to say this is a really cool prediction
um it may be impossible today but
Cutting Edge science is making the
impossible just really hard and that's
what you guys have done at bicep I mean
bicep to me I am the biggest fan of
bicep and when um I know you had I don't
know if I want to call it a misstep but
a false alarm or whatever it's called I
am your biggest Defender because you
guys set your sight on a goal and you
just you you are more sensitive in
looking for this signature uh it's an
important test of inflation because if
you find this gravitational wave
signature you find out when inflation
took place popop just like that and but
it's really really hard it's more than a
decade that you've been doing this and
you just keep I watch you guys every if
if I if I would give you $100 you would
go buy some more detectors for the focal
plane because every p penny that comes
into this project you you make the the
experiment more sensitive and it's
sitting down there at the South Pole I
hope it's running right now yeah yeah
well it's been upgraded it's on the
fourth generation now it's called bicep
array you know went from bicep one bicep
2 bicep 3 and now we uh gave up the
creative naming scheme but yeah speaking
of money that's you know you mentioned
the the royalties you're getting from
the early Universe hey friends just a
short request to ask you to use your
thumb while my thumb is occupied to
leave a like on this video and don't
forget to subscribe it really helps us
with the algorithm now back to the
episode now you understand the reason
that I'm calling you today uh Michael um
so let's talk about inflation um just a
little bit I I do want to say one thing
you brought up the very important fact
that is missed by 99% of lay people and
almost 100% of scientists which is that
the job of an experimental is not to
prove theories our job I call myself a
theory exterminator uh because that's
really what we should do and I taught my
students Michael and I wonder what you
would tell a student you know starting
off nowadays but I say my
experimentalist I want you
experimentalist to understand Theory as
well as a beginning Theory graduate
student I just don't require that you
come up with new theories or new tests
or new models but you should understand
what you're doing at least as well as a
as a theorist otherwise you're and I'm
not you know condemning plumbers and
electricians but that's what I spend
most of my time doing I'm an electrician
a plumber a technician a vacuum tube
plumber you know looking for leaks in
helium lines I mean this is not
something I needed to get a PhD and and
cosmology to do necessarily but what
would you what is the theoretical
minimum I told you the experimental
minimum I want my grad students to know
Theory at least as well as a grad
student in theory I don't require him or
her to make new theories what's the
theoretical minimum to use Lenny's term
I agree with everything you saying I'm
glad that's you're telling your students
that but what's interesting about
science and we'll come back to baseball
but I won't mention those pathetic
Padres science is a team
sport um you're in a and I don't mean
collaborations you're in a collaboration
but more generally it's a team sport so
let me just talk about the theory side
so we need theorists who write papers
where every damn one of them you can
trust you can take the numbers to the
bank and
um so that's somebody who gets on base
hits singles in theory there is a role
for people who
um swing for the
fenes the bab Bru and most of their at
bats are strikeouts we need those two
and you might say well which one do you
want I want both because if no one's on
base when you hit the home runs and so
uh and it's same in experiment I know I
know um actually in your field in the
microw background there are some people
in your field who are extremely
distinguished I don't want to mention
names because this could be taken the
wrong way but who know how to get the
science then there are people who know
how to invent the
instrumentation uh but don't have a clue
about the science but they and so if you
get those two together uh Andrew could
do both and actually Andrew also could
conduct the the orchestra so he could
put together manage the baseball team he
could manage the baseball team and so I
think science requires a whole bunch of
of different skill sets on the theory
side um but I guess all of them involve
you know being able to um work
abstractly and having a command of the
mathematics of the day I like to tell
classes that the history in the history
of science um we you may push back on
this um mathematics has always been the
pacing item pacing item and I can make a
pretty good case about that that uh you
know we had the Greeks and oh my God uh
nothing happened and then uclid invented
geometry and uh algebra helped uh the
Arabs invented algebra and then Newton
came along and invented calculus and you
can you can see where our understanding
of the universe jumped non- ukan
geometry uh Ein Stein came along it was
so abstract that uh people have a hard
time believing this Einstein was not a
very good mathematician and he had his
Hired Hand Marcel grman grman that's
right um and so mathematics a theorist
has to know math and do they have to
know
absolutely uh you know The Cutting Edge
math or can they can't know oldfashioned
math like if all you're good at is
geometry I think you might not be a
great de theorist but you you don't
necessarily have to know String Theory
so it takes a different skill sets and
you know the Weinberg Salon Theory oh my
goodness Nobel Prize winners um Shelly
who's a good friend always swings for
the fences he is the big idea guy past
guest on the podcast shell is amazing he
hates strength Theory that's a whole
another I I can't explain that we'll do
that at a different time yeah and uh
Steve sweat the
details and the combination of them
getting the Nobel Prize is so crazy
because that the two of them competed in
High School Bronx High School of Science
and there they are you know you you know
you're judging how good you are by how
many other people are at my level
there's another guy who's as smart as I
am they both end up as assistant
professors at Harvard sharing the same
secretary and then Steve gets famous for
his paper on what's now called the B
Salam glashow
model Shelley forgot he had invented the
model because it was one of his
strikeouts because he didn't have a way
that there was something missing from
the model and so then Shelly oh my God I
hope you're oh boy I'm being uh but
shelle has said all of this in print he
said Weinberg installed the toilet in
his beautiful model and that which is
the higs mechanism but so I say this
they're both brilliant you we would not
have the Weinberg Salam glash out Theory
without the two of them and Abdus Salam
and I'm sure you see it in experiment
there's some people in your
collaboration who are developing
detectors for 20 years ahead and you're
trying to say yeah but we're trying to
get these working at the South Pole
that's right and well they're not going
to help you with that we love to plan we
love to forecast ahead it's you sort of
get a little bit of the thrill of the
you know it's like when I say I want to
drop you know 5 lbs uh I'm glad to say I
did it Michael I dropped 5 lbs but it
was from my chin to my waist it wasn't
that far but um and later on I want to
ask you I have a tradition I'm going to
ask you to ask my next guest a question
my next guest is none other than Gerard
at H I can't the first thing is had he
pronounce his name uh but uh he's he's
agreed to answer some questions on the
podcast so I'd love to get a question
from you to Gard or Gerard if you're if
you're willing to play that at the very
end play that game in a couple of
minutes but um but before we do I would
be remiss I had on um this guy David
charers I don't know if you know who he
is he's he's um a philosopher at New
York University he came up with this
concept called the the hard problem of
Consciousness I had on a guy named Nick
Bostrom and he invented the term the the
um singular not the singularity that's
Ray kwi uh the simulation hypothesis so
all these guys come on and one's from
Australia and David chers is from
Australia and I said David look it would
be if it would be as if I had on you
know uh ACDC and I didn't ask them to
sing Back in Black uh you are the
Creator the Father the paternal figure
of dark energy I would be as equally
remiss as I would have been with Bostrom
if I didn't ask you know him I I gave
the example of ABA if I didn't ask him
to sing dancing queen because he's from
Sweden anyway tell me please Michael how
did this come to you what was the
motivating inciting incident from
literature we we we encountered these
what what was the origin story of your
child dark energy in the 90s when you
were a youngster uh we had this idea
called inflation it predicted a flat
universe a critical density Universe we
we had this um idea of cold dark matter
these were the driving ideas they were
getting young people like you into the
field they were so
beautiful and they had a problem let
let's focus on the critical density
problem so the critical density problem
was you have to find enough matter to
get to the critical density and early on
we looked at the measurements that had
been made by the astronomers and um we
realized they were missing the dark
matter and the dark matter is more
diffuse than the visible matter and so
and it's harder to measure things that
are far away from you and so we pinned
our hopes on the Dark Matter was going
to get
the density all the way up to one up to
the critical density in I think it was
about 1994 there was a paper I won't
describe the details that really hit me
in the face um it involved we know at
that time we knew how many uh atoms
there were we just didn't know how many
how much dark matter there was and this
paper used a very clever technique
looking at the ratio of dark matter to
ordinary matter in clusters and then
scaling it up saying that that the total
amount of ordinary matter is only about
30% you're not going to get that paper
really eliminated that the possibility
that dark matter was going to take you
all the way to one so when you eliminate
the impossible whatever's left no matter
how ridiculous I know I'm screwing up
the quote is likely to be the answer and
so you look at what could fill the Gap
and what could fill the Gap is something
like Einstein's cosmological constant
and I'd been writing papers you know
theorists are always you know this is my
main prediction but I got in my back
pocket an answer just in case your
experiment comes out a different way oh
here look at this paper the uh Lawrence
Krauss and I wrote a paper saying the
cosmological constant is back and uh
that was in 1995 and in 1998 it was
discovered blah blah blah and then I
realized in
1998 that the the astronomers were going
to say okay we're done it's just the
cosm olical constant and we do not know
that we absolutely do not know that and
so if you allowed this stuff to be
called the cosmological constant oh my
God you could youve you guys have
already measured it to better than 1%
we're done but we realized and it wasn't
for just for Full Employment it was we
don't know what it is and so unless we
change the name and explain to people
why it's mysterious unknown I've called
it the most profound mystery not the
most important mystery but the most
profound mystery so it needed a new name
so what is the new name well uh we got
Dark Matter that's really good but it's
not matter and yeah in the technical
sense and it's more like energy than it
is like matter and I'll I'll just say
that and not explain it because it's not
worth explaining so oh my God dark
energy and dark matter dark side of the
universe better better get that
copyrighted right away so there it was
and then you have to lay out the story
so we don't know what dark energy is we
we do know that the simplest example of
it is Einstein's cosmological constant
but for I won't go into all the reasons
it's a big puzzle it is a really big
puzzle and so about the same time Martin
white I came up with here's how you
determine whether or not it is Lambda
it's the just use the letter you know it
w it's the W parameter and so I made a
really big deal of this is really
important and it's got a different name
from the cosmological constant because
it may not be the cosmological constant
and you know this as well as I do today
all the measurements are consistent with
dark energy just being a cosmological
constant however if that's the answer we
don't know why we don't know why such a
cosmological concept would be so small
and so I remember the meeting it was a
wonderful meeting in Australia where I
rolled out the new name actually I don't
know if you've ever seen this the first
name I tried was funny energy and uh I
have a viewgraph that appeared in the
New York Times you're famously renowned
for your sketching your artistic
abilities the focus groups told me okay
oh that's fantastic you know that's
non-threatening people will really love
it and then I said well it's it take a
billion dollars to figure out what funny
energy is oh you need a more serious
name than that and so in August of 1998
uh at the mount stromlo meeting in in
Australia I said we're going to call
this stuff dark energy and um the name
has stuck some people don't like it they
want to call it dark negative pressure
that that I don't think the focus groups
are going to like that dark energy is
pretty good but it the purpose get rid
of all the silliness two purpose is
number one in order to make it a
scientific Target you can't just say oh
that funny stuff that's causing the
universe to speed up it needs a short
name and then you need to quantify it a
little bit and you need to differentiate
it so dark matter uh has worked really
really well but you have you have to
differentiate it from Dark Matter so
it's got to be slightly different it's
it can't be a a long complicated name
and you have to be able to explain to
people oh my God you're just trying to
be more famous than I Einstein oh no one
could ever do that so why don't you just
call it Einstein's cosmological constant
and the simple thing is we don't know
that it is it is the biggest puzzle it's
the most profound puzzle in all of
Science and if we want people to uh
really spend time trying to figure it
out we got we gota we got to give it the
right name yeah and I think it's good
speaking as somebody who's got a name
for uh not a name no pun intended for
neoism I came up with the ter name bicep
NASA recently asked me to come up with a
new name apparently the name Uranus is
very
embarrassing uh for some astronomers to
pronounce and we come up with ways
around it workarounds like Uranus like
urine is better than Uranus so I've been
tasked by the NASA task force um to come
up with a new name and I'm proud I'm
going to announce it right now I've come
up with a new name it shall be known as
Ure rectum and I think I think it's GNA
stick but up to folks like you the focus
groups will come into play Michael I
want to read I want to read something to
you and it's a it's it's kind of a
Hallmark for my for my listeners to uh
to eventually send you more and more uh
of those precious royalty uh scratch
checks um this is from an article you
wrote I believe about 10 15 years ago no
it's 20 years ago oh my God this is
incredible Michael in physics today and
it's about dark en and this is a section
called Destiny one thing you wrote is
clear Dark Energy leads to a revision in
our view of cosmic Destiny with matter
alone Destiny and geometry are one
closed universes recollapse and open or
flat universes expand forever if dark
energy is vacuum energy our flat
universe will continue accelerating to
oblique future in a 100 billion years
all but a few hundred galaxies nearby
will have their light shifted too far
into the red to be seen if Dark Energy
dissipates the universe will begin to
decelerate possibly even collapse then
go on to say dark energy is one of the
deepest and most exciting puzzles in all
of science it is likely that a crazy new
idea is needed to explain the cosmic
speed up and resolve the cosmological
constant problem that does not mean that
every crazy idea is a solution the
payoff will be well worth the effort we
will gain new insights into the nature
of matter space and time and shed light
and our Cosmic Destiny and that you said
was predicated on adding in your
nine-year-old son's theoretical work and
progress was assured but Michael I want
to I want to take a quote from a um a
very well-known science SST by the name
of alvie Cohen who um was uh in um Annie
Hall uh Woody Allen uh comes up and his
mother says you know he's not doing his
homework to the psychologist and the
psychologist why aren't you doing your
homework alvie and alvie says oh I just
found out the universe is expanding and
eventually everything will be so
diffused and nothing will be and his
mother goes shut up you idiot Brooklyn's
not expanding how do you deal with the
existential dread of your creation
Michael um I've had on Adam reee uh
hadat on Brian Schmidt on the podcast to
lovely men who you know very well they
don't seem particularly overwhelmed by
the existential you know kind of uh velt
Schurz I think is the German term uh for
you know kind of world weariness or does
this affect you I mean you write so
beautifully so poetically I can't
imagine you haven't thought of the
philosophical just as a man as a father
as a you know as as as a scholar how
does this knowledge of something you
played a huge role in unleashing upon
the universe how does it affect you if
at all maybe it doesn't maybe it doesn't
um and I may have gotten that out of my
system I started out being trained in
physics and uh at Stanford uh my adviser
wanted me to get more into astrophysics
and so I read a an astronomy book it
might have been the one by George a bell
but they're all the same it's the one
for college courses and I came away so
depressed
that was before dark energy that the
universe is so big and we're so small
and um so I kind of got that out of my
system there are people as you know you
know Doug Adams and Lawrence Krauss
Freeman Dyson wrote the kind of first
article about the long-term history of
the universe and there's so much to do
today and so much to understand
today and I'm sorry I'm giving you the
the boring uh at least company with two
Nobel Prize winners two Nobel and the
first guest on the into the impossible
podcast was none other than Freeman
Dyson he was a Jason and he used to come
to La Hoya every uh summer for some
reason he didn't like being in you know
Princeton New Jersey in uh the middle of
January so he was a brilliant guy he
came down and uh we got to know each
other and one of my favorite memories he
met my you know then four-year-old and
he was 94 whatever at the time and I
have pictures of them together he's the
lovely man he was my first guest on this
very podcast so you're in great company
Michael and you deserve it I want to ask
now about another I mean you've been at
the center of so many of these really
interesting um conundrums and I see you
there aren't the technicians there are
the kind of people the work a day people
cash the paycheck and you know uh don't
really think about the philosophical
implications I know that you're you're
saying that you've resolved those
philosophical implications but what do
you make um of these recent kind of
controversies as are as Freeman might
say or Brit might say about the the
Hubble concept the Hubble tension I want
to get into your work on magnetic fields
which is my preferred solution and and
rectification of the of the Hubble
tension first explain is it really a
problem that scientists are measuring
you know this number two different ways
to sub percent you know uh precision and
as you pointed out I think you coined
this term too uh that uh Precision
cosmology is is good but accurate
cosmology is better I use that without
giving you the royalties but that will
now change tell me Michael what do you
make
of the so-called Hubble tension what is
it and what does it mean so the Hubble
tension um talks to the maturity of
cosmology it it used to be a science
with very few facts and now there are
lots of facts there's enough facts that
we can measure things in multiple ways
and do cross checks and so we can
measure how fast the universe is
expanding just by looking at the
galaxies nearby it's not easy it's very
hard work because you have to figure
figure out their distances you can
measure it that way and then you can use
a way that's probably more familiar to
you using the microwave background and
what you really do is measure how fast
the universe was expanding a really long
time ago and then say I know Einstein's
equations tell me how the expansion rate
should evolve with time and I can um run
it up to today and it should agree with
what those who measure it doing uh now
get
and so the good news is it does agree uh
to better than
10% and oh my god when I was your age
getting a 10% measurement of the Hubble
constant almost looked impossible and it
involved Wendy fredman my Chicago
colleague leading the Hubble key project
and doing it so we have two different
methods that agree to AE a Precision
that 20 years ago would have been
enviable
but then when you look more carefully
and uh take those numbers very seriously
they
disagree as you say at at a few percent
level and and it's statistically
significant it's not just oh you know
with because errors of measurement it
and so this is an important cross check
cosmology is not used to having cross
checks we now have a bunch of them this
is an important one and so the question
is and there are three outcomes three
possibilities one the micro background
could be wrong I know you would find
that that measuring it from the micro
background could be wrong uh actually
there are four possibilities uh the
direct measurements could be wrong both
the direct and the microwave background
could be wrong they both could be right
but the extrapolation is wrong because
there's something else in the universe
besides uh atoms dark matter and dark
energy and that's what gets everyone
excited is that there's something
missing from this model I think you use
the term Lambda CDM I know Adam gets
very very excited about that and that's
a possibility and I Adam would be the
first to say we're not there yet and
then what and coming back to Dark Energy
we had a crisis then we had a bunch of
things that didn't work I I uh mentioned
the flatness but there were other
puzzles that didn't work you add one
crazy thing Lambda and everything works
and so that looked pretty good to me and
Lawrence Krauss and we wrote a paper um
today all of the fixes they're so
complicated and they just solve one
problem so you you know you put it
Fineman was one of my mentors at Caltech
and he said you know an idea is good
it's like putting a quarter in the Coke
machine and 30 Cokes come out the golden
Gumball yeah yeah and that's not
happened with the the fixes like ear
they have all kinds of names that I
could say early Dark Energy I'll say
early dark energy is the most popular
one and they don't even quite fix the
problem and then you say okay well okay
let me pretend you fixed the discrepancy
what else are you predicting what else
new is out there uh well this was just a
toy model it was not it was not meant to
so it doesn't that doesn't mean it's not
right but it doesn't have the sound of
being correct and I'm usually pretty
good at looking around the corners and
this is a real puzzle I don't see where
this is going to end in fact it would be
wonderful to have a debate where it
ended and in the debate you flip a coin
to decide who takes what side because
there are powerful arguments on both
sides oh it's got to be new physics
there's an equally powerful argument oh
my God that distance scale measuring
Galaxy distances is so hard if you look
at all the great astronomers Hubble was
off only by a factor of 10 in measuring
distances I mean it it's very hard to
measure distances in the universe so I
don't know how that one's going to end
and but the the it's either going to end
hope well I guess it could end as the
whole cosmology collapses I don't think
that'll be the case but or it could end
in oh there's a mistake either in the
microwave background or the local
measurements and now the two agree to
one% so we have this end to end test or
it could be you know what we just
discovered just like the discrepancy we
had with the flatness of the universe we
just discovered something new about the
universe so it's exciting that's the
other misconception among you know lay
people and less so among professional
scientists unlike the job of what an
experimentalist is supposed to do being
not prove a theorist but prove them
wrong but uh but actually it's most
exciting I I always think it's a little
disingenuous though Michael when people
used to say you know the most exciting
thing about the Large Hadron Collider
would be if we don't find the hgs B on
I'll be like yeah I'd be really excited
about losing 10 billion EUR you know
just you know that would be so exciting
to me but you know other than that in
this situation so many flowers can bloom
and one of the ones that I said appeals
most to me veny because I've written
papers about it with my uh with my uh
friends and in various locations like
Lon pakian and and others about um about
magnetic fields so uh your paper and and
this is the sign of just a Titanic
intellect so as we were talking before
we start recording we were talking about
your paper with Lawrence wdro back from
1988 and I said in that paper you know
it's being cited now as a um as you know
one of the first citations to axons and
so forth and and you were kind of
arguing with me Michael but I I looked
up the paper as we're as we're talking I
have it downloaded and uh and no it's
right there equation 31 uh
sorry uh you you talk about a uh the
Axion through which uh through the
anomaly couples to E.B which for those
out there uh my audience is the most
brilliant in the known universe to the
Multiverse but uh that would be a a
forbidden interaction in classical
electromagnetism but Michael is so
incredibly um you know uh brilliant that
you've forgotten more than most of us
will ever know and one of those things
was how an Axion which is become a very
popular candidate for the explanation of
dark energies you know sinister older
brother dark matter um I wonder though I
don't want to talk too much about Axion
unless you want to talk about I'm
fascinated by them and it's kind of
buttering my bread lately because we're
we're during doing a lot of searches as
is your buddy John carlstrom and and the
South Pole telescope and I like to think
I play a little role in that as I did
with the search for inflation with bicep
and that I started to think about uh
these parody violating things back in
2007 as as looking for these forbidden
correlation functions in E.B of C Cel
E.B and people even John kind of laughed
at me back then but but now he's he's
come around and I hope to have him on
the podcast too but but unless you want
to talk about axons let's talk about
electromagnetic fields because these are
the only things that we know for sure
exist we don't know if axons exists we
don't know what dark energy is or you
know maybe if it is a cosmological
constant or not we don't know what dark
matter but we certainly know good as
anything that magnetic fields exist uh
in you and me and our planet in this
meteorite which you know blew my chances
at a Nobel Prize in some ways uh but I
do give these away if you have a edu
email address I give them away on my
website Brian ke.com so you have AED
I'll I'll bring you one when I come and
see you up there in Venice but Michael
how do magnetic fields originate in what
was the concept for these early magnetic
fields and what would you rate if you
were doing a um a Hubble tension
scorecard as I would love for you to do
as you did with your magical inflation
scorecard please tell me Michael what
would the idea of a primordial magnetic
field Rank and what score would you give
it for resolving potentially the Hubble
tension well I would give any solution a
pretty low score let's go back to Dark
Energy when Lawrence and I wrote the
paper about Lambda I would have given it
a chance of maybe 10 or 20% being
correct and I really thought it was a
good idea so um the that calibrates
things yeah I want to calibrate it so I
think any of the solutions I've heard
you know less than
10% uh chance of being correct but
that's really high because there's a lot
of ideas out there and you should not
trust my opinion the uh nature gets the
last word and the experimenters get the
last word and nature or ugly experiments
kill beautiful theories and so you can
have the most beautiful Theory I don't
know if you ever had John Ellis on on
your show but he's very distinguished
partical physics physic oh no not John
Ellis I had George Ellis and John Ellis
said the first time he's very creative
guy the first time he heard about the
weinberg's law model he said this is too
ugly for nature to have chosen that and
it did and so just because all this I
find all the solutions uncompelling my
opinion really doesn't count we've got a
problem to solve and so we need ideas
and you know I'll give you this is
advice from an old person so I did a
tutorial with Fineman when I was
undergraduate Caltech and so he he looks
at me just like I'm looking at you right
now and he says I really envy your
ignorance and so I'm going oh that's
great thank you thank you very much
Professor ultimate backhanded compliment
well what he meant was on the theory
side is that the older you get the less
creative you get and you know too much
and you get a germ of an idea and you
can just completely discarded and most
ideas the first rendering of most ideas
is just wrong and so but if you kill
that little germ of an idea so for
example you know magnetic fields
explaining the the tension I'm what I'm
100% sure of is that the solutions that
have been written are not right whether
or not they have a germ of a good idea I
don't know um and so and I'm the wrong
person to ask because you get old and
you get you know so much more and worse
than that you know that most ideas are
wrong so you know if someone comes in
and says okay uh it's your life the
stakes of this question are your life is
this new idea right or wrong I'm going
with wrong because I'm I'm going I'm
going with the with the smart money
because and so and it just doesn't
matter there's so many examples I
neutrino oscillations all the theorists
said oh my God nutrin mixing angles are
really small and it's matter induced
that's so pretty uh the Creator could
not have chosen to do that it's large
mixing angles all the way the Creator
did not take the beautiful route so what
young people can do is put ideas out
there and a lot of them are just crap or
not most of them are wrong some of them
are even crap but it's generating those
ideas is the hard thing the easy thing
is being the critic and testing them is
not always easy either but so I just
don't want to discourage people from
having ideas so my current betting odds
on the Hubble problem I gave you four
Solutions um 25 25 25 25 it's a real
puzzle that's a uniform prior for those
of you playing at home um I think maybe
if I could be you know so tarius as to
suggest what Fineman uh might have also
been implying you know and and he would
have had a field day with me cuz he he
would have been very envious of my
ignorance uh cuz there there was a
surfite of it but there's a feeling that
you get yeah I finished reading Moby
Dick you know 20 years ago I I started
it 800 times never finished it um but
when I was done I was like ah I really
wish I could read this again for the
first time and you know you kind of feel
that way sometimes when you're building
a new experiment you know in those heady
early days or I assume a theory coming
up with a theoretical idea but um but
it's just so it's it's it is it is
important to realize that yes ideas on
the one hand ideas are cheap and
everybody's got an idea and the hard
thing is follow through which takes a
lot more time and attention and so forth
but I think being Guided by these big
principles trying to do as as you know
another great oror said you know that
the Mankind's reach should exceed his
grasp that's the challenge that's what
makes it so fun to be a physicist when
there are so many different
possibilities that that you could be
right you could be wrong and and you
should have a little bit I always say
you should have a humble you know kind
of form of of swagger you should you
should know that you're probably wrong
but if you don't have a little Cockiness
you're never going to take on Mother
Nature you know she's just too powerful
so let's conclude in the next you know
few minutes if you have a few more
minutes Michael I'd love to talk about
um your thoughts on um on you know
upcoming guests I have two upcoming
guests that you know very well one is
Katie Freeze um uh who you wrote many
papers with but also with with um David
Shram who uh who I I never really got to
know David he passed away unfortunately
you know before I came of age but um
talk about you know Katie um who's
coming he's she's actually coming to
UCSD in a in a week to give our uh prize
colloquium here um but talk about their
ideas she's come to attention lately for
this notion of dark stars um and that
possibly being an explanation uh I
wonder if you could you know Channel
your friend Lake colleague David and say
what would he make of these new ideas
and what do you make of of of of these
very creative ideas like uh dark photons
dark stars help us you're the king of
the dark Michael so please opine for us
on the state of this and then uh we'll
conclude in a bit David shm was my
mentor and um I will never forget the
day uh that that he died I just um I
don't even want to think about it and
Katie was a student at Chicago and David
was was her advisor and I also worked
with Katie when she was a student and so
dark stars is really great um I can't
possibly believe it's true uh I can't
find out anything wrong with it but most
importantly it's very testable and I
also like um what you said about the
Swagger Katie's had the right amount of
swagger that U you got to let go of an
idea if somebody can show you that it
doesn't work but if it's testable that's
very important and Steve Weinberg once
said that you can find countless
examples where the theorist did did not
stick to their ideas enough the
microwave being background being one gam
off uh they could have predicted it they
could have even anyway that's it's an
interesting dicky dicky dicky did
predict it and tried to measure it and
then he forgot about it it um and so I
think the dark stars I just can't
possibly believe it's correct and then
Katie says well tell me what's wrong
with my arguments and tells me what's
wrong with these simulations and that
would be amazing um the dark photons so
this is another one that uh it'd be
interesting to get Katie's opinion on
this here we have a
dilemma uh my generation said guess what
uh we've got it down there's one dark
matter particle uh it completes the
grand unified theory or The Theory of
Everything there's just one particle
missing and guess what that one particle
missing also is the dark matter we've
got this really Simple Story we called
the 2010s the decade of the wimp uh of
the weakly interacting massive particle
and you're either looking for the
lightest super symmetric particle or the
Axion and Rocky and I and others said by
by 2020 will be done we'll we'll know
the answer and well of course we never
we don't quite know the answer we
haven't ruled either one out but it's
not looking good and so the young
theorist said the new paradigm is the of
the iceberg is the Dark Matter particle
and the rest of the iceberg underwater
that we can't see is a whole new Dark
World all kinds of other particles dark
dark photons dark this dark that it
seems awfully extravagant to me for one
problem you invent a whole new world but
the uh they've convinced me that I'm
being fairly simple-minded saying you
know we just had one thing left to do
and now a question for a took
uh well he's so smart and he thinks
about things in a very deep way um I was
at a meeting with him uh five years ago
and I was trying to think but I would
really like to know his opinion on
inflation Roger Penrose who I don't know
if you've had on your show or not but
many times he does not think very highly
of inflation and he thinks that it's
just a blind alley and you've probably
had Andre Lind who thinks you know yeah
and Andre Lind once said the only way
you can disprove inflation is with a
better Theory you can't do it with an
experimental data and he thinks very
highly of it
I uh Gerard thinks about things in a way
that I can't often understand and he's
extraordinarily mathematically powerful
when I hear him talk about black holes I
know I can't understand that I get
confused by that but I would love to
have just open-end did what do you think
about inflation are we on the right
track is it is it a distraction where
where is that train going okay Michael
the last question I usually ask a bunch
of questions based on Sir Arthur C Clark
uh who is the namesake of this podcast
because he said the only way to know the
limits of the possible is to go beyond
them into the impossible you brought up
Arthur Conan Doyle's similar statement
but I want to um and and sometimes I lay
on my department chair uh Clark's other
Maxim which is that for every expert
there's an equal and opposite expert I
love that one but I'm going to do a
different one uh also having to do with
impossibility and it's the following
quote when an elderly or distinguished
scientist says something is possible he
is very likely to be correct but when he
says something is impossible he is very
likely to be wrong I want to ask you
Michael um what have you been wrong
about uh what have you changed your mind
about and and sort of an and sort of an
advice to an earlier form of Michael I
think we just covered the one that I'm
struggling with and I think the the
struggle struggles are really big you
know this dark matter thing have I for
the most of my career been looking at it
the wrong way that it's either the Axion
or the neutralino and you've heard the
wimp miracle I hate that term uh it's
not you will not find it in the early
Universe because it it seems clear to me
I mean you heard me kind of dismissive I
didn't mean to be dismissive but saying
this whole idea that you're inventing a
dark world to explain one experimental
fact that seems so extravagant but maybe
I'm just looking at it the wrong way
that this is the piece the only piece of
the dark world that we can see and I'm
just so fixed in my old ideas that
there's just one last thing to find like
Michaelson was saying oh you know in the
1900s physics is done we're just putting
extra decimal places on so I would say
that for me you're watching ing a
struggle and I I give talks I'm have to
give talks at dark matter meetings and
I'm slowly evolving I'm at least willing
to admit they may be right and usually I
can see around corners and see the end
this puzzle I cannot see around the
corner Michael I appreciate you so much
uh I hope you'll come down to San Diego
and maybe give a colloquium of your own
now we'd love to host you here and uh
it's been a delight as I knew it would
be and I I hope someday we can do a part
two it's been fascinating Journey
Through the history and your philosophy
and also the culture and taste that it
takes to build a brand as strong as the
Turner brand thank you so much and uh
best of luck to everyone that you
mentioned except for those hated Dodgers
thanks a lot Brian it's been it's been
fun and I do hope I will get down to San
Diego one of these days